Eric box here with another new rockstars
hot take that's giving me existential
Panic official character posters for
Ant-Man that was quantum Mania depict
the character's bodies unwinding into
ribbon shapes it looks a lot like the
way in the trailer Scott Lang strodinger
variant unravels in that Nexus Zone I
wonder if this could be what it looks
like on a subatomic level when a
character is pruned from existence the
tightly coiled bundle of timelines that
forms each of us the knot of temporal
streams that defines our existence must
be unraveled for us to be erased yes
it's a pretty terrifying way to think
about yourself not as tissue or cells or
molecules or atoms or a soul but rather
just multiversal strands of alternate
choices and light paths all converging
into one and when someone just pulls the
right chord we could all just
disintegrate into temporal spaghetti